That is your perceptual reality.
The physical reality is that those two tiles are the same.
Here you see four gray tiles on your left,
seven gray tiles on the right.
I'm not going to change those tiles at all,
but I'm going to reveal the rest of the scene.
And see what happens to your perception.
The four blue tiles on the left are gray.
The seven yellow tiles on the right are also gray.
They are the same. Okay?
Don't believe me? Let's watch it again.
What's true for color is also true for complex perceptions of motion.
So, here we have --
let's turn this around -- a diamond.
And what I'm going to do is, I'm going to hold it here,
and I'm going to spin it.
And for all of you, you'll see it probably spinning this direction.
Now I want you to keep looking at it.
Move your eyes around, blink, maybe close one eye.
And suddenly it will flip, and start spinning the opposite direction.
Yes? Raise your hand if you got that. Yes?
Keep blinking.
Every time you blink, it will switch.
So I can ask you, which direction is it rotating?
How do you know?
Your brain doesn't know, because both are equally likely.
So depending on where it looks,
it flips between the two possibilities.
Are we the only ones that see illusions?
The answer to this question is no.
Even the beautiful bumblebee,
with its mere one million brain cells,
which is 250 times fewer cells than you have in one retina,
sees illusions, does the most complicated things
that even our most sophisticated computers can't do.
So in my lab we work on bumblebees,
because we can completely control their experience,
and see how it alters the architecture of their brain.
We do this in what we call the Bee Matrix.
Here you have the hive.
You can see the queen bee, the large bee in the middle.
Those are her daughters, the eggs.
They go back and forth between this hive and the arena, via this tube.
You'll see one of the bees come out here.
You see how she has a little number on her?
There's another one coming out, she also has a number on her.
Now, they're not born that way, right?
We pull them out, put them in the fridge, and they fall asleep.
Then you can superglue little numbers on them.
(Laughter)
And now, in this experiment they get a reward if they go to the blue flowers.
They land on the flower,
stick their tongue in there, called a proboscis, and drink sugar water.
She's drinking a glass of water that's about that big to you and I,
will do that about three times, then fly.
And sometimes they learn not to go to the blue,
but to go where the other bees go.
So they copy each other.
They can count to five. They can recognize faces.
And here she comes down the ladder.
And she'll come into the hive, find an empty honey pot,
and throw up, and that's honey.
(Laughter)
Now remember, she's supposed to be going to the blue flowers,
but what are these bees doing in the upper right corner?
It looks like they're going to green flowers.
Now, are they getting it wrong?
And the answer to the question is no. Those are actually blue flowers.
But those are blue flowers under green light.
So they're using the relationships between the colors to solve the puzzle,
which is exactly what we do.
So, illusions are often used,
especially in art, in the words of a more contemporary artist,
"to demonstrate the fragility of our senses."
Okay, this is complete rubbish.
The senses aren't fragile. And if they were, we wouldn't be here.
Instead, color tells us something completely different,
that the brain didn't actually evolve to see the world the way it is.
We can't.
Instead, the brain evolved to see the world
the way it was useful to see in the past.
And how we see is by continually redefining normality.
So, how can we take this incredible capacity of plasticity of the brain
and get people to experience their world differently?
Well, one of the ways we do it in my lab and studio
is we translate the light into sound,
and we enable people to hear their visual world.
And they can navigate the world using their ears.
Here's David on the right, and he's holding a camera.
On the left is what his camera sees.
And you'll see there's a faint line going across that image.
That line is broken up into 32 squares.
In each square, we calculate the average color.
And then we just simply translate that into sound.
And now he's going to turn around,
close his eyes,
and find a plate on the ground with his eyes closed.
(Continuous sound)
(Sound changes momentarily)
Beau Lotto: He finds it. Amazing, right?
So not only can we create a prosthetic for the visually impaired,
but we can also investigate
how people literally make sense of the world.
But we can also do something else.
We can also make music with color.
So, working with kids,
they created images,
thinking about what might the images you see
sound like if we could listen to them.
And then we translated these images.
And this is one of those images.
And this is a six-year-old child composing a piece of music
for a 32-piece orchestra.
And this is what it sounds like.
(Electronic representation of orchestral music)
So, a six-year-old child. Okay?
Now, what does all this mean?
What this suggests is that no one is an outside observer of nature, okay?
We're not defined by our central properties,
by the bits that make us up.
We're defined by our environment and our interaction with that environment,
by our ecology.
And that ecology is necessarily relative, historical and empirical.
So, what I'd like to finish with is this over here.
Because what I've been trying to do is really celebrate uncertainty.
Because I think only through uncertainty is there potential for understanding.
So, if some of you are still feeling a bit too certain,
I'd like to do this one.
So, if we have the lights down.
And what we have here --
Can everyone see 25 purple surfaces on your left,
and 25, call it yellowish, surfaces on your right?
So now, what I want to do,
I'm going to put the middle nine surfaces here
under yellow illumination,
by simply putting a filter behind them.
Now you can see that changes the light that's coming through there, right?
Because now the light is going through a yellowish filter
and then a purplish filter.
I'm going to do the opposite on the left here.
I'm going to put the middle nine under a purplish light.
Now, some of you will have noticed that the consequence
is that the light coming through those middle nine on the right,
or your left, is exactly the same as the light
coming through the middle nine on your right.
Agreed? Yes?
Okay. So they are physically the same.
Let's pull the covers off.
Now remember --
you know that the middle nine are exactly the same.
Do they look the same?
No.
The question is, "Is that an illusion?"
And I'll leave you with that.
So, thank you very much.
(Laughter)
(Applause)